House Majority Leader Nancy Pelosi
became a member of Congress through a
special election 30 years ago she has
led House Democrats for the last 14
years including a stint as the first
female speaker but the democratic
party's losing streak in recent special
elections prompted some House colleagues
to question her leadership Nancy Pelosi
was a great speaker
she is a great leader but her time has
come and gone I think it's time for
change and these election results
frankly show that we're gonna regain the
majority in 2018 we have to have new
leadership you think Nancy Pelosi is
more toxic than Donald Trump
you know what the honest answer is in
some areas of the country yes she is
that's the honest answer congressman
Nancy Pelosi good morning good morning
you want to respond like I'm here and
we're hearing all these other people
they had their time on TV but this is
such a small item it isn't about me
right now
our fight is about the Affordable Care
Act I've always had a challenge in the
caucus right from the start when I was
ok but let's look at this - you have
been losing special elections ok and
four of them and people say it's because
the Democratic part of what you were
leader has no message your only message
is anti-trump know that is it first of
all let me just say these are four races
we would never have chosen declined they
were chosen by Donald Trump for races
where double-digit lead for the
Republicans in previous election we
picked up 70 points 25 and one raced 15
20 like that in the four races the
people in those states are very happy
because we pushed the Republicans very
far back made I like to win but this was
I the people in Georgia work very hard
in Montana all of those places and
they've made great progress leading up
there but again there are 70 races that
are easier for us than any of those we
would never have chosen to go in there
was so much excitement in the country to
to act against the election in November
so this isn't
let's this these people were against me
last November they started this before
the fact is the fact is this I glad in
an event of six to take us to the
majority became Speaker of the House
President Obama became president he was
their spokesperson for eight years we
just lost the election we could write a
message but the fact is we need our
members to write the message and they
know full well that that is something
we're working with the Senate to go
forward why don't you think you should
step aside let me tell you why I should
stay instead I'm a master legislator I'm
an experienced in terms of knowing the
institutional memory of Mother Congress
if Hillary Clinton had won I might have
gone home but with Donald Trump in the
White House with a Republican majority
in both houses no way after president
Trump won President Obama came out I
remember being at the White House and he
said Democrats are characterized as
coastal liberal latte-sipping
politically correct out of touch folks
we have to be in those communities how
do you do that 20 mr. president for
eight years I don't think he was
describing himself but in that way he
was describing the challenge you have in
2018 but it is it we always have a
challenge and that is again I take it
back to Affordable Care Act so many
people benefited from it some of them
voted for Donald Trump so we have to if
you ever say to people it happens with
your spouse as well if you think you're
communicating and they don't think
you're communicating you're not
communicating so it isn't about our
agenda that isn't even a better message
it's a better communication of it and
the right now of this week we're in a
fight for our lives and the lives of
many people in our country because we
must defeat what is going on in the
Senate you said you were master
legislator let's see your sense of where
the Congress is what kind of bill will
come out of the Senate and and we know
that well the President and will the
Republican get enough votes in the
Senate to pass it I don't think anybody
knows that right now maybe Mitch
McConnell does but right now at this
moment on Monday we haven't seen the CBO
report yet we do know that
the many more people millions hundreds
of thousands of people will die if this
bill passes but you don't think there's
room to fix this legislation you're
saying out of hand no no let me be very
clear thank you for that question the
Affordable Care Act we can work together
to others and Democrats can fix it
absolutely and what we had hoped that
president Trump would want to do from
the start instead of sabotaging it some
of the ills of it or because of the
Republicans when they took power not re
renewing some of the things that were in
there and any bill that is passed
you see implementation and you know how
you can improve it but these bills
systemically structurally they are very
very harmful to the American people they
will raise cost that with fewer benefits
have an age tax if you're 50 nobody here
of course 50 to 64 they will undermine
Medicare that they will throw millions
of people tens millions of people off is
there anything that you know though that
you think that you all can work with
they can sit down nothing willing to
actually know it's not a question of
willing structurally this undermines
Medicare in the long run this is so
essential this bill passes and goes back
to the house can it pass in the house it
depends on Hep C right now they're going
to the right in order to pick up votes
and if they pick up votes on the right
then they may lose the moderate votes
that they got in the house it's great to
have you either it's my pleasure to be
here and we have to have people write
their Senators write their Congress
people and you're not going anywhere
well I stay at the pleasure of my caucus
and I'm very pleased with the support
that I have from them thank you for
joining us my pleasure there's one when
Nancy Pelosi